Vastra und vermeiden Sie die Milano-Schulden minus
H-Bar bei Hunden und fragen Sie nach der Version der
Ionen auf Kind, noch von der Tour, auch individuell,
einen Link, Sir zu ABBA Vasundhara Victors
VAR im Fernsehen, klopfen Schlager und schütteln
Monster Tough Aveda, aber Kobold reden von
Pixelmon, wenn ein netter  mittel, ein mögliches Dose-
Video, gemacht mit Ammoniak, NH Ferguson, dann
öffne den Link mit etwas Boden, also
ist meine erste Frage jedes Mal, wie es
läuft. Du weißt, dass du Deutsch lesen würdest,
ja, genau erstaunlich, ja, Mann, du weißt, ich
kann mich nach zwei oder drei nicht beschweren  Es waren sehr, sehr
schwierige Jahre, in denen ich vielleicht
dachte, dass ich so eine Gelegenheit nie wieder bekommen würde.
Nun bin ich
Ende 2011 mit einigen großen Erfolgen zurechtgekommen
und ich bin überglücklich. Okay, ist es
schwierig, sich für eine Pause zu entscheiden?  in
der Karriere und etwas anderes zu tun,
als deinen Kollegen zu verlassen und es wie
du zu tun, Eddie, nun ja, es war nicht meine
Entscheidung, eine Pause einzulegen, du weißt, dass die
Entscheidung für mich getroffen wurde, angesichts der
Umstände um dich herum, das
Schöne  Das Besondere am Leben als Songwriter
und Künstler ist, dass all diese
schwierigen Situationen wieder in
die Musik und in die Kreativität einfließen,
aber ich kam mit dem
anderen Mitglied von Mattafix Pritesh nicht klar. Du
weißt, wir verstehen uns jetzt großartig, aber bei  Die
Zeit, in der es sehr, sehr schwierig war, hat bei EMI
einige Turbulenzen erlebt, und bei meinem
Plattenlabel wurden wir fallen gelassen, und
die schöne Frau ist gegangen, und
es gab all diese verrückten, verrückten
Ereignisse, die mich irgendwie
in eine Krise getrieben haben  Wo ich
eigentlich nur ein Soloalbum hätte schreiben können,
was denkst du in dieser
Situation, wenn sie passiert? Glaubst du, dass
Oreo die Situation sieht und
denkt, dass sie schlecht, schlecht, schlecht ist, oder du siehst die
ganze Situation und denkst vielleicht nach?  Es ist
gut für sie, also ist es etwas. Ja,
ich denke, es hängt davon ab, zu welcher
Tageszeit du mich erwischst. Ok, du weißt,
morgens ist alles deprimierend und ich
kann keine
Blinds kennen, und dann nimmst du vielleicht die
Gitarre und fängst an zu fühlen  Besser
über die Dinge, aber ich denke, intellektuell
und an der Oberfläche gibt es eine Menge
Selbstzweifel, weißt du, selbst du weißt, als
autodidaktischer Musiker weißt du, ob ich gut
genug bin, um das zu tun, habe ich eine gute
Stimme, kann ich gut genug spielen?  Kann
ich diese Songs schreiben, um mich dorthin zurückzubringen?
Weißt du, was ich falsch gemacht habe?
Weißt du? Hat sie mich in all diesen Dingen aus einem
bestimmten Grund verlassen?
Und es wird einfacher, wissen Sie,
nachdem Sie diese
Situationen ein paar Mal durchgemacht haben, und ich denke,
selbst in den wirklich unglücklichen Tagen
war der Songwriter in mir grob, jeder
rieb sich die Hände aneinander und ging dorthin, wo
Sie wissen, dass das hier hinführt  Ich werde
manchmal tolle Musik machen,
dann habe ich traurige Momente in meinem Leben. Ich
denke, okay, da hieß es, aber ich lebe und
es ist eine gute Zeit, bestimmte Situationen zu haben.
Ja, da war fast
etwas Schönes daran,
ihr wisst schon  Die Klarheit des Schmerzes
ist ziemlich schwer zu beschreiben,
und ich weiß nicht, was ich damit gemacht hätte,
ohne Musik, ohne dieses
Ventil, aber es war ein echtes Erwachen,
wissen Sie, was das bedeutet? Gespräche mit
Menschen, die schwierige Zeiten durchmachen,
sind völlig  Jetzt ist es anders, ich meine, ich kann mich
auf eine völlig andere Art und Weise einfühlen,
es ist, als wäre ich fast die Person, die man
kennt, und ich fange an, mich so zu fühlen. Das war
wirklich erstaunlich. Ich denke, der Trick für mich besteht
jetzt darin, zu lernen, wie man Musik macht, wenn
ich glücklich bin  Okay ja, lass uns das Problem am besten
lösen, vielleicht mal sehen, wann sich etwas
in deinem Leben verändert, wenn es schlecht wurde, denn
die Inspiration war all die Dinge,
die gut passiert sind, alle Ereignisse
passierten auf einen Schlag, wir kamen
mit Mattafix von der Tour und der Schutz selbst
war es nicht  Wir haben uns nicht verstanden, wir haben
nicht geredet, wir sind sehr offen darüber.
Ich habe einige Fehler in meiner
Beziehung gemacht und war mit einer
schönen Frau verlobt
Damals hatte ich familiäre Probleme, und dann
wurde EMI von einem Hedgefonds aufgekauft und sie
fingen an, alle zu entlassen, mit denen ich zusammengearbeitet hatte,
und schließlich ließen sie uns fallen,
sodass all diese Dinge innerhalb von fünf
oder sechs Monaten passierten. Wow, aber es hat noch
zwei Jahre gedauert  Daraus einen Sinn zu machen und
klar genug denken zu können, um
Songs darüber zu haben, die tatsächlich funktionieren und
etwas bedeuten und nicht wie „Oh mein
Gott, das ist deprimierend, denn
eigentlich weiß man, dass New Age erst
vor zwei Jahren kam.“  Das alles ist
passiert, also weißt du, dass es der Auslöser
für alles war, aber ich war auch in
einer ziemlich klaren Stimmung, als ich
viele Songs schrieb, also ja, es ist ein
interessanter Prozess. Wenn du also anfängst,
dein Album aufzunehmen, warst du dabei  Der
Prozess oder es war am Ende,
also, es war ein ständiger Kreislauf, weißt du,
nach allem, was passiert ist, bin ich in die
Karibik gereist, um zu versuchen, mich zu erholen, und habe
ungefähr 15 wirklich raue Akustiksongs geschrieben,
du weißt schon, wirklich sehr, sehr raue,
von ziemlich ruhig reichend  Gut, schrecklich zu gefallen,
und ich ging zurück nach England und nahm
sie alle mit Mike und meinem
Keyboarder Richard auf, und wir legten sie einfach auf,
okay, um zwei, drei Bänder aufzunehmen,
und emotional und körperlich war ich
zerstört, weißt du, ich war es gewesen  Ich war
einige Jahre unterwegs und weißt du,
bestimmte Beziehungen werden
mir genommen, und das war wirklich eine gute
Erfahrung. Wir haben
diese Songs aufgenommen und zwei davon landeten auf
dem Album, aber es war ein sehr wichtiger
Prozess  Da war „Brotherhood of the
Broken“ und auch ein bisschen „
Antihero Will“ war dabei,
und nach dieser Erfahrung hatte ich irgendwie
mehr Selbstvertrauen mit der Gitarre
und dem Gesang und ging zu Mr.  Guy
Chambers, er ist ein sehr berühmter Songwriter,
und wir haben zusammen New Age geschrieben. Er setzte sich mit
mir zusammen und er sagte: „Ich glaube, du weißt, dass
du ein Solokünstler bist, du hast die
Stimme und du weißt, wie man ihn sagen hört, dass er
jemand ist, der mit den ganz Großen zusammengearbeitet hat.“
Weißt du, das war eine Inspirationsquelle für
mich, dann bin ich nach Amerika gegangen, habe die Hälfte der
Platte in den Staaten gemacht, weißt du,
überhaupt kein Geld, kein Label, keine Kontakte. Ich
bin einfach hingegangen und habe gedacht, mal
sehen, was passiert, und das weißt du  Das
kann einem in den Staaten passieren, wenn
man mit einer Idee kommt und die Dinge
sehr schnell ins Rollen kommen, und ich habe
mit einigen der talentiertesten Leute an
der West- und Ostküste zusammengearbeitet, also ja, wenn man
jetzt zurückblickt, weiß man, dass es
irgendwie so ist  Eine surreale Geschichte, aber zu der Zeit
war ich einfach total in das vertieft, was ich
tat, aber du hattest Geld in den USA, nein,
wie du einen Stern wert bist, vorher war mein Ja,
aber ich habe alles auf dieses Album geworfen,
für ein verfügbares Ja, und es ist ein  Mythos,
dass du einen Treffer hast, ja, und jemand
steckt dir eine Million Euro in die
Tasche, du weißt, du weißt, nachdem der
Steuermann seinen Teil abkassiert hat, ja, weißt du, und
vielleicht weißt du, ich habe eine kleine
Wohnung in London gekauft, du weißt, ich bin sehr
komfortabel, versteh mich nicht falsch, aber ich habe
wirklich viel
in dieses Album gesteckt, also ja, ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher, dass
einer der Ratschläge,
die ich jungen Musikern geben werde, vielleicht ist
Als Künstler haben wir uns schuldig gemacht,
die Realität des Geschäfts falsch dargestellt zu haben.
Das bedeutet nicht zwangsläufig,
dass alles in Ordnung ist, sobald man einen Hit bekommt.
Ich meine, es geht mit
jahrelanger harter Arbeit und dem Aufbau einer
Plattform einher  für dich selbst, aber manchmal
könnte ein Treffer ausreichen, wenn du an
letztes Weihnachten denkst. Ja, genau Sony, aber
heutzutage weißt du,
wo Downloads
andere sind, ja, die bevorzugte Option sind,
aber New Age, ich denke, das ist es  Ein Lied
wie Last Christmas, was ich für New
Age halte, ist ein Lied. Es ist ein echtes Lied mit allem, was ein
Lied braucht: Es hat eine Melodie, es
hat eine Struktur, es hat alles, es
hat einen guten Sänger, es hat alles, seine
Glocke ist arrangiert, denke ich  hat das Potenzial,
wirklich ein Song zu werden, den die Leute,
glaube ich, in 10 oder 20 Jahren kennen werden. Danke,
was ist ein Geheimnis, Alter. Ja, weißt du,
wenn ich wüsste, dass ich es jeden Tag machen würde, ja,
du weißt, ich hätte 365 Hits gehabt  Ein Jahr lang,
weißt du, zunächst
einmal wollte ich mit unglaublich
talentierten Leuten zusammenarbeiten, also kam der Typ dazu,
aber ich wollte auch mit Leuten arbeiten,
die eine einfache Popmelodie verstehen, aber
du weißt schon, Leute, die eine klassische Ausbildung haben,
du weißt schon, auch sehr, sehr versierte Musiker
Ich liebe die Kombination
dieser beiden. Wir sind nie auf der Suche nach
einer neuen Idee,
denn er verfügt über
ein musikalisches Fundament, und deshalb war es
wichtig, dass der Gesang sehr
nahe am Mikrofon eines deutschen
Mikrofons aufgenommen wurde  und auch nicht ja und neun Jahre oder
nicht oder nicht okay, weißt du, und ich kann mich
auf Deutsch mit der bahnbrechenden Mikrofontechnologie der Deutschen befassen,
aber das ist eine
andere Sache, aber eine sehr, sehr genaue
Aufnahme, sodass es sich anhört, als wäre ich im
Auto oder ich wäre drin  Mit dir in der Küche oder
ich bin mit dir im Schlafzimmer, welche Hexe
ist, was für mich auch sehr wichtig ist, und
ja, und nur eine Geschichte und eine
Wahrheit, du kennst jedes Wort dieses Liedes,
es ist absolut wahr, an dem Tag, als ich reinkam, habe
ich es getan  Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Liebe
bedeutet, weißt du, obwohl ich hätte
wissen müssen, dass ich älter und angeblich
erfahrener bin als je zuvor, und ich
saß da ​​und hob die Hände und sagte: „
Ich weiß, es ist cool, was auch immer es ist,
es ist cool, aber.“  Weißt du, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie ich das irgendwie lösen soll,
oh ja, okay, aber wann wusstest du, dass
das ein Hit werden würde, war gut, das könnte
es sicherlich nicht sein, als wir es hier geschrieben haben,
nein, weil du es weißt und ich es hasse
Als ich hörte, wie wir das sagten, dachte ich, du dreckiger
Bastard, du kannst es nicht wissen, weißt du,
denn wenn du einen Künstler sagen hörst, dass es
in zwei oder drei Stunden geschrieben wurde,
weißt du, dass du unseren Mann so
nervig findest, aber er war eigentlich New Age  Ich habe es
in ein paar Stunden geschrieben, aber wenn ich
jetzt zurückblicke, wird mir klar, dass es das
Ergebnis jahrelanger harter Arbeit war,
an diesen Punkt zu gelangen, sodass es so
mühelos und so einfach geht, Mann und ich saßen
dann da, als wir vielleicht eine dritte Single von
dir haben  Weißt du, okay, das geht
eigentlich nicht unter die Dusche, aber langsam fing ich an,
es den Leuten vorzuspielen. Die Leute reagierten. Meine
Plattenfirma hier in Berlin war die
erste, die mir
einen Universalvertrag unterschrieb, als ihnen ganz,
ganz klar war, dass es ein unglaublich
unglaublicher Song ist, den wir für dich halten.  Als
Solokünstler ist das unser Plan und ich habe mich
auf mein Bauchgefühl verlassen und gesagt: „Weißt du,
ich denke, diese Jungs wissen, wovon sie
reden, also denke ich, als Künstler
weiß man es, man hat eine klare Vorstellung, die man
manchmal hat.“  Eine klare Richtung, aber
manchmal ist es großartig, Leute
um sich zu haben, die einem gute
Ratschläge geben. Ich denke, als wir unser
Video in Berlin aufgenommen haben, konnte man es sehen,
denn ja, diese Bühne, ja, auf der wir nicht waren,
ist nicht so berühmt wie heute, ja  Und die
Leute kamen und hörten sich die Musik an,
ja, und sie waren davon inspiriert, ja,
und ich denke, nur in Deutschland kann es
eine Situation geben, in der man anfängt,
ein Lied zu spielen, und alle eine Menschenmenge bilden, und
ich hielt inne und sagte, können alle einfach
rübergehen?  Wir sind auf diese Seite gegangen, weil wir
die Beleuchtung besser fotografieren wollen.
Können wir uns alle bewegen und alle sind einfach
gehorsam auf die andere Seite gegangen, und ich
dachte: Wow, weißt du, du weißt, nicht nur, dass
du sehr loyal bist, sondern sie
wollen es wahrscheinlich auch?  Ich habe hier etwas gehört,
das war also interessant. Ja, ich denke,
es war ein großartiger Moment dort, aber ich
saß auch in einem Auto, ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
wo ich auf einer der schönen
deutschen Straßen und einer der Autobahnen war,
und das Lied kam  zwischen zwei Top-
5-Platten, die sehr schnell und sehr
hart waren, und dann kam New Age und es
klang einfach so, als wäre ein Hauch frischer
Luft dabei, ja, und ich glaube, dann wurde mir klar, oh
mein Gott, warte einen Moment, das ist das
Großer, großer, großer Radiosong und ja, das
war ein Moment, der war ein Moment, okay,
hier sehr, ja, ich mag es, wie du
mich dazu gebracht hast, es zu finden, wir sind überall hin gerannt
und sind dann zu dir zurückgekommen, ok,
vielen Dank, sehr brillant, danke  Damen
Videofilmer hatten Jungs Alpha Z
Hadassah mich gemacht, ich verdammter Victor Volt Isaiah
und Sänger Kite, komm schon, lieber lieber Phil
Ozz Anaheim, unser Kasachstan, nur ein Aufkleber,
verzerrt VAR bei besagtem Besitz und und August
dort im Gespräch, genial vom Air Safaga
English Team ist VEC Lager  Das ist Tomas,
die Pasta von Mann Johnson, Vivaro Sama,
ja, Stan,
du